Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速告诉大家一件正在发生的令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“迈向经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Unpaid, yet seemingly essential. Controversial yet coveted. Picture this,
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有由Lisa本人直接提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导时间。想了解更多吗？当然想。前往我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目。无薪，却看似必不可少。有争议，却又令人垂涎。想象一下，
aspiring psychologists navigating a landscape where experience often comes at the detriment of actual compensation. But why the buzz around honorary assistant psychologist roles? What secrets do they hold? Why are they so unethical? Join me for today's episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, where we unravel the enigma surrounding these positions and delve right into the heart of the debate. Stay tuned and I hope you find it so it's so useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I am a qualified clinical psychologist. Now recently on my LinkedIn and on my Instagram, I am Dr. Marianne Trent in both of those places where I said, what gives me the ick? And the answer was advertising of honorary assistant psychologist posts. And it's true. It does. It feels a bit yuck. Before we dive
有抱负的心理学家在这样一个环境中摸索：经验往往是以牺牲实际报酬为代价的。但为什么关于“荣誉助理心理学家”职位的讨论如此热烈？它们隐藏着什么秘密？为什么它们如此不道德？欢迎收听今天的《有抱负的心理学家》播客，我们将揭开这些职位的谜团，深入探讨这场辩论的核心。请继续收听，希望你觉得这非常有益。嗨，欢迎来到《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是Marianne Trent博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。最近在我的LinkedIn和Instagram上（这两个地方我都是Dr. Marianne Trent），我提到了什么让我感到反感，答案就是招聘“荣誉助理心理学家”职位的广告。这是真的，确实如此。感觉有点恶心。在我们深入
into this episode where we're exploring the seven reasons why honorary assistant positions are controversial, let me quickly take you through a little bit of definition about what I mean. So typically an honorary assistant psychologist position would be one where somebody might be working in a hospital or a clinic or a research setting, usually supporting qualified psychologists to deliver a service that they provide. The roles of an honorary assistant psychologist might be conducting assessments, supporting with admin tasks, scoring assessments, starting to make a start on writing letters, maybe collecting data, sometimes even administering interventions like therapy groups alongside hopefully qualified staff. But unlike formal
探讨本期节目之前，我们将探讨荣誉助理职位具有争议的七个原因，让我先快速为你定义一下我的意思。通常，荣誉助理心理学家职位是指某人在医院、诊所或研究机构工作，通常协助合格的心理学家提供服务。荣誉助理心理学家的职责可能包括进行评估、协助行政任务、评分评估、开始尝试写信、收集数据，有时甚至在合格员工的协助下进行干预措施，如治疗小组。但与正式的
assistant psychologist roles, these roles are unpaid. So what we're not talking about necessarily here is a separate debate. We're not talking about placement student roles. We're not talking about master's placement roles. We're not talking about undergraduate sandwich year placement roles, which can be quite common. And I understand that they are not paid. But for me, this issue is when you see a company advertising honorary assistant psychologist roles. So yeah, it's a whole different debate, the unpaid placement, which helps you then get your qualification that you are obviously paying and wanting to develop. That is not really the main topic of this podcast, although very important debates too. What we're talking about is people asking for people to come into their service and work for free doing highly skilled work. That's what we are discussing today. So with no further ado, let's look at reason one, why this is a controversial hot potato. Well, it may not surprise you that I'm leading with this first reason, and that is exploitation
助理心理学家职位不同，这些职位是无薪的。所以我们在这里讨论的并不一定是一个单独的辩论。我们不是在谈论实习生角色，不是在谈论硕士实习角色，也不是在谈论本科三明治课程实习角色，这些都很常见，而且我理解它们是不带薪的。但对我来说，这个问题在于当你看到一家公司在招聘荣誉助理心理学家职位时。所以是的，这是一个完全不同的辩论，无薪实习可以帮助你获得资格，而你显然是在付费并希望发展。这并不是本播客的主要话题，尽管这也是非常重要的辩论。我们讨论的是人们要求他人进入他们的服务机构并免费进行高技能工作。这就是我们今天讨论的内容。那么，废话少说，让我们看看第一个原因，为什么这是一个有争议的烫手山芋。好吧，我提出第一个原因你可能不会感到惊讶，那就是对劳动力的剥削。
of labour. You might well see this in NHS settings, and I'm starting to see it crop up in private practice as well. You know, some people feel fiercely protective of the fact that this happens in NHS services, but it still isn't okay. Asking people to come and work for you for free, to travel to and from your work base, to buy their own lunch, to, you know, often to pay their own parking, it's not all right. It's not all right to the person doing that role. It's not all right to the people who cannot afford to do that role. Some people might say it's only a day or two a week. It's fine. It's not fine because that's actually a big chunk. That's 20 or 40% of what could be the full-time equivalent salary. And I'm concerned that it creates the context where free labour is part of the service that's built in.
你可能在NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）环境中看到这种情况，而且我开始看到它在私人诊所中也出现了。你知道，有些人对这种情况发生在NHS服务中感到非常保护，但这仍然是不对的。要求人们免费为你工作，往返工作地点，自己买午餐，甚至经常自己支付停车费，这都是不对的。这对做这份工作的人来说是不对的，对那些负担不起这份工作的人来说也是不对的。有些人可能会说这只是一周一两天，没关系。这不对，因为这实际上是很大一部分。这可能是全职等效工资的20%或40%。我担心这创造了一种将免费劳动力作为服务一部分的环境。
We're, you know, allowing staffing needs to partly come from free labour. And that's not OK. That's not OK. Because this is important work that we're asking people to do. It's exploitative. And my relic is when you see it in private practice, where people are actually charging money. It's allowing the qualified psychologists to earn more money because they're not having to pay a virtual assistant or they're not having to do the role themselves.
我们，你知道，允许人员需求部分来自免费劳动力。这不对。因为这是我们要求人们做的重要工作。这是剥削性的。当你在私人诊所看到这种情况时，我的反感就更强烈了，因为人们实际上是在收费。这让合格的心理学家赚更多的钱，因为他们不必支付虚拟助理的费用，或者他们不必自己做这份工作。
It's not okay. It's stinky. I'm not all right with it. And of course, what we know in certainly NHS organisations is that we still need our honorary or voluntary staff to be trained. And so you get the position of inequity where you might well be sat next to a band nine, band eight D, band, you know, whatever psychologist who is perhaps new to the trust as well, doing their mandatory training and knowing that they're getting paid, you know, quite a nice wedge of money and you are getting paid zero. And gone are the days where you often get free lunch. So there's not even the perk there. Massively exploitative. So point number two is inequitable access.
这不对。这很糟糕。我无法接受。当然，我们知道在NHS组织中，我们仍然需要我们的荣誉或志愿人员接受培训。所以你会处于一种不平等的境地，你可能坐在一个九级、八级D级心理学家旁边，他可能也是刚加入信托基金，正在进行强制性培训，知道他们拿着相当不错的薪水，而你却一分钱也拿不到。而且现在已经没有免费午餐了，所以连那个福利都没有了。这是极大的剥削。所以第二点是不平等的准入。
This is creating gaps for those who can or can't afford to pursue their career in psychology. So of course, those who can afford to work in honorary capacity might be likely to be younger. And I know that actually a big chunk of my podcast listeners are actually a little bit older. So some of my most popular episodes, certainly on YouTube, have been those that feature older applicants. So I know this matters. I know this is important. And what we know is that, of course, these honorary assistant roles do actually help people's career. If we're only allowing people to get a bump start, if they can afford to work for free, that means we're discounting people who are parents. We're discounting people
这为那些能够或不能负担得起从事心理学职业的人制造了差距。当然，那些负担得起以荣誉身份工作的人可能更年轻。我知道我的播客听众中有很大一部分其实年龄稍大。所以我在YouTube上最受欢迎的一些节目，确实是那些以年长申请者为特色的节目。所以我知道这很重要。我知道这很重要。我们知道，这些荣誉助理职位确实有助于人们的职业生涯。如果我们只允许那些负担得起免费工作的人获得起步机会，那就意味着我们排除了那些为人父母的人，我们排除了那些
who don't have maybe parents to let them live with them for free or to take reduced rent. We know we're discounting so many different types of people and we're giving the red carpet treatment with the gold spangled banners to people who can afford to work for free. So yeah, it's just that inequitable access. It's the platform not being level for all that makes this so unjust. Point number three is access to supervision and professional development. Now, as an honorary member of staff, you're not always really counted in the numbers. People often don't even really know your name. They might well talk about you behind your back as the honoree. You're seen as more transient and you might not regularly have access to supervision. You may feel like you're having to chase people for supervision because probably there's not really the job plan hours of time to be able to supervise you because this is probably something that's
可能没有父母让他们免费居住或减少租金的人。我们知道我们排除了许多不同类型的人，而为那些负担得起免费工作的人铺上了红地毯。所以是的，这就是不平等的准入。正是因为平台对所有人来说都不公平，才使得这如此不公正。第三点是获得督导和专业发展的机会。作为一名荣誉员工，你并不总是被计入人数。人们甚至经常不知道你的名字。他们可能会在背后谈论你作为荣誉员工。你被视为更具流动性，你可能无法定期获得督导。你可能会觉得你不得不追着别人要求督导，因为可能没有真正的工作计划时间来督导你，因为这可能被认为是
been thought of as a stop gap to plug gaps in the service, not necessarily something that's been thought about in any great detail. And it's often thought about to plug gaps in the service rather than to further your own development and think about how well contained and supported you feel. One AP who listens to the podcast told me that they had left an honorary assistant psychologist position because they felt the management was really horrendous and that it meant that somebody who condoned this level of honorary role, went out of their way to recruit and appoint to it, was less likely to rally for change, you know, and to think that that job was worthwhile and that that person deserved to be paid for doing that role. So there's something around the services and the
被认为是填补服务空白的权宜之计，而不一定经过深思熟虑。它通常被认为是填补服务空白，而不是为了促进你自己的发展，考虑你感到多么被包容和支持。一位收听播客的助理心理学家告诉我，他们离开了一个荣誉助理心理学家职位，因为他们觉得管理非常糟糕，这意味着一个纵容这种荣誉角色水平的人，费尽心思去招聘和任命它，就不太可能为改变而奔走，你知道，去认为那份工作是值得的，那个人应该因为做那份工作而获得报酬。所以关于服务和
supervisors who are condoning these honorary assistant psychologist roles. Without that proper supervision, without, you know, appraisals, you're not necessarily going to develop in the same way as you would as if you were in that paid capacity. Perhaps you're not getting access to the training courses that would help further your development, but that your paid counterparts might well be getting access to. And of course, what we know is that not all honorary roles are classed or counted in the same way as paid roles by people screening applications. And of course, if you're not doing that honorary role full time, it can take really quite some time to score the adequate days, months, years to be able to get what looks reasonable on your CV.
纵容这些荣誉助理心理学家职位的督导们，有一些问题。没有适当的督导，没有评估，你就不一定会像在带薪职位那样发展。也许你没有获得有助于进一步发展的培训课程，而你的带薪同行可能正在获得这些机会。当然，我们知道，筛选申请的人并不总是以与带薪职位相同的方式对所有荣誉职位进行分类或计算。当然，如果你不是全职从事那个荣誉职位，可能需要相当长的时间才能积累足够的日子、月份、年份，以便在你的简历上看起来合理。
So yeah, just to summarise on point three, it's just that you are not feeling like you're being treated the same as other people. You're not being afforded the same time for supervision. You're not being afforded the same time for development. You're not being afforded the same time for development and that could hinder you. That could hold you back. Point number four will be coming up after this short break. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book.
所以，总结一下第三点，就是你感觉自己没有受到像其他人一样的对待。你没有获得同样的督导时间。你没有获得同样的发展时间，这可能会阻碍你。这可能会拖累你。第四点将在短暂休息后出现。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南。充满了将帮助你获得资格的经验教训。所以来看看吧。就在这本书里。
It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. Welcome back. So in the first half of our episode, we were looking at the first three reasons why honorary assistant psychologist posts can be so controversial. Dive back in and have a little look at point number four. being advertised and kind of continuing and perpetuating the treadmill of honorary assistant psychologists being present in services means that we become acquiesced to that, that we perhaps more likely to just accept it and not fight for change and not fight for these positions to become paid. You know, if we're continuing to deliver the services,
它是《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。它是《临床心理学家集体》。它是《临床心理学家集体》。欢迎回来。在节目的前半部分，我们看了荣誉助理心理学家职位之所以如此有争议的前三个原因。让我们回到第四点。被广告宣传，并以某种方式持续和延续荣誉助理心理学家的跑步机存在于服务中，意味着我们对此变得默许，我们可能更容易接受它，而不去争取改变，不去争取这些职位变成带薪职位。你知道，如果我们继续提供服务，
of course, public services are very important. I'm not saying they're not, but people and human development is also really, really important. And some people are saying, well, we can't run this service without honorary assistants. Maybe we need to start voting with our feet and saying no to supervising honorary assistant psychologists and saying no to delivering interventions with people who don't have the privilege of being paid. You know, it's just a basic right, isn't it? You do a job, you do a day's work, you get paid for it. So the more and more we see these posts advertised, the more and more they will continue to happen. And so perhaps we need to buck the trend of this normalization, start putting boundaries in place and start saying no.
当然，公共服务非常重要。我不是说它们不重要，但人和人的发展也非常非常重要。有些人说，没有荣誉助理，我们就无法运行这项服务。也许我们需要开始用脚投票，拒绝督导荣誉助理心理学家，拒绝与那些没有获得报酬特权的人一起提供干预措施。你知道，这只是一个基本权利，不是吗？你做一份工作，你做一天的工作，你就会得到报酬。所以我们看到的这些广告越多，它们就会持续发生得越多。所以也许我们需要打破这种正常化的趋势，开始设定界限，开始说不。
So point five is the ethical considerations. There's ethical considerations around for honorary assistant psychologists as well. So if they're working in private practice, do they have their own indemnity insurance? How are they coping with any moral or ethical dilemmas that might crop up? You know, things like confidentiality, boundaries, you know, tricky questions that you might get asked by clients. Do they have the necessary training, skills, expertise, supervision to be able to do justice to that role and to the service that they're representing? And do they have the relevant number of hours supervision with somebody who's looking after them and looking out for them. I think that's a really important consideration. Are they seen as a person or are they just seen
所以第五点是道德考量。荣誉助理心理学家也有道德考量。如果他们在私人诊所工作，他们有自己的赔偿保险吗？他们如何应对可能出现的任何道德或伦理困境？你知道，像保密、界限、客户可能问你的棘手问题等事情。他们是否有必要的培训、技能、专业知识、督导来公正地对待那个角色和他们所代表的服务？他们是否有与照顾他们和关心他们的人进行相关小时数的督导？我认为这是一个非常重要的考量。他们是被视为一个人，还是仅仅被视为
as someone to help support the service? Are they getting invited to team lunches? Are they getting to spend time shadowing other members of the team, not just doing the role you want them to do. It's an ethical and moral minefield. So point number six is the impact upon diversity and upon the profession. When we advertise honorary assistant psychologist roles, we are often advertising for people who are already psychology graduates, who would technically be capable of fulfilling perhaps a band four, a band five NHS paid assistant role. And we're asking these people to work for free. Often there is the essential criteria and the person spec requirements of, you know, basically the same as a paid role.
一个帮助支持服务的人？他们会被邀请参加团队午餐吗？他们能花时间跟随团队的其他成员吗，而不仅仅是做你想要他们做的角色。这是一个道德和伦理的雷区。所以第六点是对多样性和职业的影响。当我们广告招聘荣誉助理心理学家职位时，我们经常是在为那些已经是心理学毕业生的人做广告，他们从技术上讲有能力胜任NHS的四级或五级带薪助理职位。而我们却要求这些人免费工作。通常有基本标准和个人规格要求，基本上和带薪职位一样。
But we're saying, could you maybe just do that for free? If you do work in the NHS, or you have experience of working in the NHS, if you consider for a moment the admin teams, and often the complexity of work that you're asking admin staff to do will be metered out to them by their supervisors based on the qualifications and the expertise level of that person. Now if you think about the work that might be done for you by a band four or band five admin member of staff, what I'm sure we won't find is people doing honorary band four or band five admin roles because they are seen as highly skilled and experienced admin work. And yet, the same does not seem to be true for highly skilled and experienced qualified psychology
但我们说，你能免费做吗？如果你在NHS工作，或者你有在NHS工作的经验，如果你考虑一下行政团队，通常你要求行政人员做的工作的复杂性将由他们的督导根据那个人的资格和专业水平来衡量。现在，如果你想想四级或五级行政人员可能为你做的工作，我相信我们不会发现人们在做荣誉四级或五级行政职位，因为它们被视为高技能和经验丰富的行政工作。然而，对于高技能和经验丰富的合格心理学
graduates. We're asking for the same person spec, the same job description, as if they were being paid, but of course they're not. This is something I was chatting about with Gavin Clark, who's joined us for two recent podcast episodes, one on distance learning masters and one on navigating psychology from a wheelchair. He was sharing with me that in the legal profession, honorary roles are really, really common. And it seems that psychology are learning from that, but it's not okay. And I feel like in the legal profession, people should know more about morals and ethics. And we don't want to be continuing and perpetuating this narrative that it's acceptable for psychology graduates to work for free. It's
毕业生来说，情况似乎并非如此。我们要求相同的个人规格，相同的职位描述，就好像他们正在获得报酬一样，但当然他们没有。这是我和Gavin Clark聊天时谈到的，他参加了我们最近的两期播客，一期是关于远程学习硕士，一期是关于坐轮椅导航心理学。他和我分享说，在法律行业，荣誉职位非常非常普遍。心理学似乎正在向他们学习，但这不对。我觉得在法律行业，人们应该更了解道德和伦理。我们不想继续和延续这种叙事，即心理学毕业生免费工作是可以接受的。这
not okay. We need to start taking control, saying no, we need to stop advertising these roles. So in terms of the impact on the profession, we're undervaluing the role that these honorary assistant psychologist personnel are doing for the service. And we shouldn't be. Again, if we look at the kind of inequity of this situation, we look at how the diversity of the profession is being impacted upon. It might well be only certain demographics who can afford to do these roles and so we're perpetuating perhaps the white middle class young aspect of psychology. Point number seven is self-belief. So if someone has only ever been paid zero pounds and zero pennies for their work and not had adequate supervision and felt like they had to chase for containment and support, they may well actually be going into interviews for paid roles, feeling that they're not quite good enough or that they haven't had the time spent enriching them that they deserved. They may feel less experienced or less able or capable than people who have been in paid roles compared to
不对。我们需要开始掌控局面，说不，我们需要停止广告招聘这些职位。因此，就对职业的影响而言，我们低估了这些荣誉助理心理学家人员为服务所做的工作。我们不应该这样做。同样，如果我们看看这种情况的不平等，我们看看职业的多样性是如何受到影响的。可能只有某些人口统计学群体负担得起做这些角色，所以我们可能正在延续心理学的白人中产阶级年轻化方面。第七点是自信心。所以，如果一个人在工作中只获得过零英镑零便士的报酬，没有得到足够的督导，并且觉得他们必须追逐包容和支持，他们可能在参加带薪职位的面试时，觉得他们不够好，或者他们没有得到他们应得的充实时间。他们可能觉得比那些在带薪职位的人相比，经验不足或能力不足，
them. So this could really knock them, it could really impact on them and their self-belief and that's our final point, that's our point seven. If they go into these honorary assistant roles thinking that it will further their career but actually knocks their confidence, that could then hinder their professional growth and development. So to summarise, these honorary assistant roles are a little bit different than placement roles, which are usually sourced and supported by universities. We've been talking today about services that are advertising, purposefully recruiting to honorary assistant roles. We need to think more about the person. We need to think more about the equity. We need to think more about
这可能会打击他们，这可能会影响他们和他们的自信心，这就是我们的最后一点，我们的第七点。如果他们带着认为这会促进他们职业生涯的想法进入这些荣誉助理职位，但实际上打击了他们的信心，那可能会阻碍他们的职业成长和发展。所以总结一下，这些荣誉职位与实习职位有点不同，实习职位通常由大学寻找和支持。我们今天谈论的是那些广告招聘、有目的地招聘荣誉助理职位的服务机构。我们需要更多地考虑人。我们需要更多地考虑公平。我们需要更多地考虑
what we might be able to do to rally the change, to stop this happening. We need to think more about this and the impact it has upon people, upon teams, upon services and upon the career and professional development as a whole. We need to stop exploiting people in our profession and I know it's difficult if you are looking to get your foot on the rung of the ladder for your next career move in psychology but perhaps we need to call upon you to stop applying for these roles. Because, you know, I created a role for myself as an honorary assistant psychologist. You know, I've been quite open about that in my book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, and in the podcast in the past previously too. It did help me.
我们能做些什么来团结起来改变，停止这种情况的发生。我们需要更多地考虑这一点以及它对人、团队、服务以及整个职业和专业发展的影响。我们需要停止剥削我们行业中的人，我知道如果你想在心理学职业生涯的下一个阶段迈出第一步，这很困难，但也许我们需要呼吁你停止申请这些职位。因为，你知道，我自己也为自己创造了一个荣誉助理心理学家的角色。你知道，我在我的书《临床心理学家集体》中，以及在过去的播客中，对此都非常坦诚。它确实帮助了我。
It helped me to get to grips with psychology terms it helped me to get a feel for what I should and what I could be saying and thinking and doing it helped me be able to say I'd done this I'd done that but it helped me more than it helped the service I would say in that example and this still wasn't okay you know it did help me to get my first paid role which wasn't in that service. It was in a completely different service and a completely different organization. I'm not saying they're not helpful, but I'm saying it's not ethical. I'm saying it's not fair. It's not right. And as we do learn and grow and develop in our career, we can make different choices than those which we've
它帮助我掌握了心理学术语，它帮助我感受到了我应该说什么、想什么、做什么，它帮助我能够说我做过这个、做过那个，但我会说在那个例子中，它对我的帮助比对服务的帮助更大，但这仍然是不对的，你知道，它确实帮助我获得了我的第一份带薪工作，那不是在那个服务机构。它是在一个完全不同的服务机构和完全不同的组织。我不是说它们没有帮助，但我是说这不道德。我是说这不公平。这不对。随着我们在职业生涯中学习、成长和发展，我们可以做出与我们
made in the past. People contact me all the time you know several times a week to say Marianne is there anything I can do for you? Can I do some honorary assistant work? Can I come and do a placement with you? And I say no because I don't think it's fair to them. I haven't yet got a predictable way of being able to help make someone's experience useful to them, but also useful to me in a way that it can help me to increase my revenue to then be able to pay them. And I'm not willing to have people work for me for free. I don't think that's how it should work. I'm in the business of building up aspiring psychologists, of equipping them with all of the resources they're going to need to
过去所做的不同的选择。人们一直联系我，你知道每周几次，说Marianne，有什么我可以为你做的吗？我可以做一些荣誉助理工作吗？我可以和你一起实习吗？我说不，因为我觉得这对他们不公平。我还没有找到一种可预测的方法来帮助使某人的经验对他们有用，同时也对我有用，以一种可以帮助我增加收入从而能够支付他们报酬的方式。我不愿意让人免费为我工作。我不认为事情应该这样运作。我从事的是培养有抱负的心理学家的事业，为他们配备他们所需要的所有资源，
hopefully live a really prosperous, enjoyable career as a psychologist. I don't want to be ill-equipping or stripping away what they think about themselves or their capabilities or their abilities. And if I'm going to make money out of something that somebody has done, or if it's going to help me to deliver a service that then means I can charge money, I think that that ought to be being passed on to the people that are supporting that role as well. I think everybody working in an assistant psychologist capacity, supporting and enabling qualified psychologists to do their job more efficiently more effectively and in services where money is being exchanged
希望他们能作为心理学家过上非常繁荣、愉快的职业生涯。我不想削弱或剥夺他们对自己、能力或才干的看法。如果我要从某人所做的事情中赚钱，或者如果它将帮助我提供一项服务，从而意味着我可以收费，我认为这应该也传递给支持该角色的人。我认为每个在助理心理学家职位上工作，支持和使合格的心理学家能够更有效、更高效地工作，以及在有金钱交换的服务机构中工作的人，
i believe people should be paid but also even in services such as the nhs which where they are free at the point of delivery there is still money involved this is still essentially supposed to be a profitable business. So staffing costs and looking at commissioning of the services. What are we commissioning for? Are we asking for adequate staffing to run our therapy groups, to be able to do our assessments, to be able to support the admin roles surrounding paid psychologists? This is such a big and important discussion. I would love your thoughts on this. Please do come along. Follow me on socials. Connect with me. Get involved with the posts that I mentioned on Instagram and on LinkedIn. Please do come along to the Aspiring Psychologist
我相信人们应该得到报酬，而且即使在像NHS这样的服务机构中，它们在交付点是免费的，但仍然涉及金钱，这本质上仍然应该是一项有利可图的业务。所以人员成本和查看服务的委托。我们委托什么？我们是否要求足够的人员来运行我们的治疗小组，能够进行我们的评估，能够支持带薪心理学家周围的行政角色？这是一个如此巨大且重要的讨论。我很想听听你对此的想法。请一定要来。在社交媒体上关注我。与我联系。参与我在Instagram和LinkedIn上提到的帖子。请一定要来参加《有抱负的心理学家》
Community free Facebook group. Let me know what you think to this. If you're watching on YouTube, please do subscribe. Please do like. Engage with the content. Let me know what you think to this if you're watching on youtube please do subscribe please do like engage with the content let me know what you would like more of from me and if you find the things i talk about useful please do consider checking out the clinical psychologist collective book the aspiring psychologist collective book and if it's your time and you're ready for the next step, please do consider joining the Aspiring Psychologist membership, which gets really wonderful reviews. Thank you so much for trusting me to help you with your understanding of psychology and developing your
社区免费Facebook群组。让我知道你对此有什么看法。如果你在YouTube上观看，请一定要订阅。请一定要点赞。参与内容。让我知道你对此有什么看法，如果你在YouTube上观看，请一定要订阅，请一定要点赞，参与内容，让我知道你希望我多做些什么，如果你觉得我谈论的事情有用，请一定要考虑看看《临床心理学家集体》这本书，《有抱负的心理学家集体》这本书，如果时机成熟，你准备好迈出下一步了，请一定要考虑加入《有抱负的心理学家》会员，它获得了非常好的评价。非常感谢你信任我，让我帮助你理解心理学并发展你的
career. I love creating this podcast for you. I will look forward to bringing the next one to you from 6am on Monday for the mp3 version and usually the weekend before on YouTube thank you so much for being part of my world and stay kind to yourself With this podcast I feel sad to be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's
职业生涯。我喜欢为你制作这个播客。我期待着在周一早上6点为你带来下一期MP3版本，通常在周末之前在YouTube上发布，非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分，对自己好一点。有了这个播客，我感到很难过，因为你正在通往合格的道路上。这是《有抱负的心理学家》播客，我是Marianne Trent博士。我叫Yana，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书，我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣，这让我感到惊讶，有这么多不同的途径可以到达那里，而且
no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
没有完美的途径成为一名心理学家，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力，所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你感到安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。